شبه الجزيره العربيه الحقيقه كانت يعني
جسر لنقل الحضارات من مكان الى اخر فهي
تنقل حضاره الموجوده الحضارات الموجوده
والافكار والاراء والاديان كانت موجوده
مثلا في افريقيا او في شمال الشرق الادنى
القديم الى اسيا الى اسيا والعكس صحيح لا
يمكن ان يحدث التجاره
كانت وما زالت منذ الازل تاتي من اسيا
وتمر بالبحر المحيط الهندي او الخليج همم
عمان وبحر العرب ثم تدلف الى الجزيره
هكذا كانت ثم تذهب ثم صبها الاخيره الى
اوروبا هكذا كانت الحركه صحيح صحيح لكن
انا ودي انابه الى شيء همم طول العمر وهو
بعض الناس الحقيقيه يعتقد او يعيد
التميز الحضاري ان كان تميزا حضاريا في
الجزيره العربيه الى كونها الى كونها فقط
لا ارى ذلك اطلاقا ال- ال- الممرات الطرق
هذه نعم كانت تمر بها لكنها ليست الاساس
في بروز الحضارات والجزيره العربيه
الانسان تمت عوامل داخليه الانسان نفسه
الفكر الذي يتبناه هذا الانسان المنطقه
الذي الذي عاش عليه هذا الانسان هو الذي
بنى هذه الحضارات وهو الذي بنى هذه
المراكز الحضاريه المتميزه والمدن
والممالك المتميزه دائما الحقيقه يؤلمني
عندما نقول بان الله مدمن مدن طرق
التجاريه او مدن القوافل هذه ليست محطه
تجاريه هذه مجتمعات ادى دورها اثرت وتاثرت
تقبلت الاخر وحاربت الاخر مثل اي مجتمع
اخر استطاع ان يجعل له اساس في في التاريخ
القديم وفي الحاضر وان شاء الله في
المستقبل همم لذلك التجاره كانت عامل من
عوامل لو لم يكن انسان
قابل لتقبل هذه التجاره ونقلها معها
وتعامل معها بشكل صحيح لما مر من عندك انا
اخذت طرق اخرى لكنهم تعاملوا مع علي انه
كان قادرا على هذا التعامل تعاملوا معنا
كان الى درجه عاليه من الرقي سواء كان في
جنوب الجزيره العربيه او شمالها او وسطها
نحن نتكلم عن شبه الجزيره العربيه كلها
فلذلك كل هذا كل هذه الانسان العربي الذي
عاش على هذا على هذه الارض كان له دور
كبير في في ابراج في في
ولاده الحضاره في في بلاده والثقافه
الموجوده عنده نعم نعم استعداد الانسان من
الجزيره العربيه لان يتفاعل مع الاخر
وقوته ننتجه حضارته الخاصه لما لما مرت
لما اصبح مركز الاتجاه مركز
الجزيره العربيه كان يتاثر الانسان
يتاثر
بمحيطه وفي نفس الوقت يصبغ على هذا
التاثير ثقافته وحضارتي
مش يستقبل فقط
في الفتره الاسلاميه وبعد في الفتره
العثمانيه ايضا عندما هاجر الكثيرين من
الجزء العربيه كل هذه الحضارات وكل هذه
الاقوال
والقبائل التي هاجرت
والجماعات البشريه كلها اثرت في تلك
المجتمعات لا شك في ذلك يعني عندما تجد
استخدام اللغه الساميه اللغه العربيه
القديمه في اللغه الاكاديه في همم تجد
مظاهرها في السومريه انا ذاك الدلاله
قاطعه على وجود على اثر الجزيره العربيه
على اثره العربيه وغيره من همم وغيره
الحقيقه انك ابدعت يا دكتور سليمان في هذه
النقطه
وايضا وضع الامور في نصابها هو هو منتج
للحضاره وليس مجرد همم محطه تمر به
الحضارات لا هو ايضا ينتج هذه الحضاره
لكنه يؤثر ويتؤثر فيها والنقطه العظيمه
اللي اشارتها لولا انه مهيء للتعامل مع
تعقيدات التجاره والدبلوماسيه وعلاقاتها
لما كانت لنزاح الطريق يمينا او شمالا او
لذهب في امكنه اخرى
المملكه القتاليه كيف تتعامل مع التاجر
انا طبعا اراها قد تكون قاسيه شويه وليست
عمليه لذلك قتبا كانت
منعز له ولم تخرج خارج قبان لكن القوانين
ذات التي تنظم تجاره همم ستجدها كان
تتشابه مع مع قوانين اليوم